samedi soir lors de la cérémonie de
clôture du Festival de Cannes la
réalisatrice française Justine Trier a
remporté la Palme d'or pour anatomie
d'une chute problème sous le coup de
l'émotion et l'on oublie son diplôme
l'actrice américaine Jane Fonda tente de
la rattraper avant de perdre patience et
de lui jeter tout simplement le
parchemin dans le dos un geste
surprenant qui amuse les internautes
certains y voit une réponse au discours
polémique de la jeune femme quelques
minutes plus tôt d'autres la félicitent
pour ses talents cachés de lancer Gérald
Darmanin qui lance une grande opération
pour la sécurité des femmes tout au long
de l'été 5 millions de flyers vous êtes
distribués par des policiers et des
gendarmes afin de sensibiliser Rémi aux
violences faites aux femmes notamment
lorsqu'on est témoins d'une agression
exactement c'est fire's donc seront
distribués partout en France à partir de
demain oui alors le standard explose
depuis ce matin ça déborde d'appel de
femmes enthousiastes c'est la joie c'est
la liesse merci Gérald bravo Gérald
enfin des actions concrètes Darmanin
2027 la voix des femmes a été entendue
on a des flyers contre les agressions
Gérald tu nous protège encore mieux que
le Weez ultra enfin quelqu'un qui nous
comprend ce qui aurait été bien c'est un
flyer à destination des hommes violents
et sexiste parce que
non comme d'habitude tu as lu fire comme
d'habitude on parle aux victimes si tu
as été alors faites plutôt si faites
plutôt ça dirigez-vous en fait comme
d'habitude la responsabilité nous
incombe or quand on est victime de
quelque chose il y a un coupable il y a
quelqu'un qui nous harcèle qui nous
viole qui nous agresse et eux on ne leur
parle jamais si vous êtes témoin de
l'agression d'une femme par quatre
individus dans une ruelle sombre
n'hésitez pas téléchargez le flyer
anti-agression de sur votre téléphone
mobile et aller voir les agresseurs holà
messieurs avez-vous lu bien lu le
prospectus du gouvernement il indique
que votre démarche est-il légal
désormais vous ne pourrez plus dire que
vous ne saviez pas si les individus ne
vous enfoncent pas alors votre téléphone
dans le renflement brun n'hésitez pas à
prévenir les autorités au moyen de ce
dernier comment on peut se retrouver
dans un porno à l'insu de son plein gré
vous voyez non mais ça fait rire les
jambes parce que c'est la référence
Papin ah oui oui à l'insu de son plein
gré donc va découvrir ce matin grâce à
vous de nouvelles sensations grâce aux
nouvelles technologies
[Rires]
psychokinophone le truc je fais un truc
pour nous
alors
plateforme
de où on paye pour voir des gens c'est
pas qu'on payait je pensais que c'était
une exhibitionniste
donc enfin on va retrouver un peu des
sensations
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais pas pour pas pour faire payer pour
ça à l'exhibitionniste gratuit oui mais
pas voilà
ça c'est un peu dégueulasse quoi son
histoire c'est waouh
comme quoi mais qui a pas que dans les
films il n'y a pas que dans les séries
il y a aussi dans la vraie vie et ouais
ça existe et c'est chaud 18000 euros
pour rester allongé alors faut avoir
quand même le coeur bien accroché oui
pendant deux mois quand même donc ça
c'est la condition c'est à tout le
clinique spatial de Toulouse on a les
premières images de la position que vous
allez devoir tenir pendant 2 mois voilà
ça ressemble à ça alors vous avez quand
même l'ordinateur pour vous occuper mais
faut tenir heureux j'ai envie de dire
oui le roi Charles et son épouse Kamila
sont à la recherche de leur community
manager officiel autrement dit un expert
des réseaux sociaux pour un salaire de
40.000 euros par an vous aurez la
responsabilité des comptes Instagram
Twitter et Tik Tok du couple royal
l'annonce précise tout de même que ces
contenus seront visionnés par des
millions de personnes la monarchie
britannique se lance à la conquête
d'Internet et donc des jeunes car
seulement 28% des 18 24 ans la
soutiendrait selon un sondage donc deux
mois lit incliné moi 6 degrés pour des
questions de circulation sanguine repas
douche pose toilette inclus euh ils sont
tous comme ça pas avoir commencé là à
Toulouse alors vous allez avoir un peu
d'activité physique ça c'est nouveau
dans les expériences sur les questions
d'apesanteur Stan Wawrinka a gagné je
vais lui passer un petit coup de ce
qu'il a gagné match de foot en 5 7 Stan
Wawrinka qui est à la maison
actuellement chez je sais que vous savez
il va dormir à la maison il va bien me
faire chier
énormément
il perd les deux autres quand la guerre
en Ukraine s'invite sur les cours de
Roland Garros
bien sûr le débat sur la présence
d'athlètes russes au prochain Jeux
Olympiques 2024 à Paris mais chaque
chose en son temps hier la 39e mondiale
à gauche sur votre écran l'Ukrainienne
Marta costume affronté la numéro 2
mondiale à droite la biélorus arrina ça
balenca sportivement la logique fut
respectée mais après sa défaite la
joueuse ukrainienne originaire de Kiev à
celui et l'arbitre vous allez la refusé
de serrer la main de son adversaire
cette Marta costume qui avait déjà snobé
une adversaire biéloruss il y a un an et
elle continuera de le faire si ça ne
tenait qu'à elle d'ailleurs elle
boycotterait carrément ces matchs mais
elle regrette un manque de courage du
tennis féminin dans une formule qu'il a
encore ne fait pas forcément l'unanimité
je cite on est des filles on a pas de
couilles selon votre théorie il faudrait
toujours deux femmes pour satisfaire
sexuellement un homme une qui sera la
pénétration une qui le stimule avec sa
langue et vous dites en revanche il
suffit d'un seul homme pour faire jouer
vraiment une femme je voulais te
féliciter je suis en plateau je suis en
direct
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une très bonne nouvelle pour toi
on va fêter ça ce soir
alors en fait ça ce soir je vais te
bouffer le cul
et moi il y a quelque chose qui m'a un
petit peu perturbé dans cette histoire
c'est que selon vos propres standards en
fait il faudrait aussi deux hommes pour
faire jouer une femme un qui avait
naître et un qui utilise sa langue et là
je me suis dit tiens incroyable Michel
Houellebecq ne connaît pas le clitoris
vous savez que j'ai été cambriolé et non
seulement bon j'avais reçu un coffret
d'une amie qui m'avait demandé de faire
de la promo qui s'appelle Clara Morgane
donc ils avaient mis tous les ustensiles
comme ça bien en évidence et ils m'ont
volé mon string éléphant et j'ai dû
annoncer ça à la police non seulement
ils ont ils ont dû se dire dis donc
Plaza et il s'amuse bien en fait le
vagin clitoris c'est quand même proche
quoi
oui je sais que c'est pas la même chose
merci mais on peut faire les deux en
même temps alors que le gland et les
couilles c'est lointain
quant au sexe des anges et des
extraterrestres on ne le connaît
toujours pas mais l'important est
ailleurs et oui car rappelez-vous
toujours que il y a deux catégories
d'OVNI l'ovni tender et l'oeuvre ni trop
jolie